hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions on my
game thrones video this weekend I know
that there's a lot of questions about
stuff happening behind the scenes we're
starting to learn some stuff from the
production so I tried to address a few
those questions in the most non spoilery
way possible that being said just
careful for spoilers on everything
that's happened on the show so far so
here we go first up samwise asks do you
think the wall will come down next
season like they're speculating with a
break the internet event this was
someone behind the production I can't
remember who said it is speculating like
one of the actors is saying there's
going to be a break the Internet moment
they say that every year and no I think
it's a little too soon for the wall to
be coming down I do think that they'll
be doing some crazy book moments from
the northern plotline bringing the wall
down isn't one of those things it
depends on how fast they want to move
the plot line along ideally what I'd
like to see is that the war for the Don
like the big final battle goes down in
season 8 because that's what their
billing is the final season so naturally
you'd expect the biggest battles to
happen then and in order for that to
happen the White Walkers have to move
south of the wall so the walls going to
come down I think it would be like at
the end of season 7 it would be like
their season 7 episode 9 or 10 thing
where everyone's just like all hope is
lost and White Walkers come running down
into the Seven Kingdoms that way they
can spend most of season 8 in like a
giant battles just stretched across 10
episodes I'm also hoping that by the
time donairs gets her [ __ ] together and
gets her army to Westeros the White
Walkers will have already moved south of
the wall most if not all hope will have
already been lost next question Trump w
asks the top sharpest minds in the game
of thrones universe so you're asking
about the smartest characters there are
definitely like a lot of smart
characters although some of them have
already left King's Landing just taking
from the people that we have on the show
people that have demonstrated great
intelligence i would say Varys is
probably at the top of the list if not
near the top Tywin Lannister also very
close to the top but he's dead now
Tyrion right up there with Vera's the
difference between those two is that
bears has been working the long con the
Targaryen restoration for a long long
time and he has his network of little
birds that Tyrion does not have but just
looking at sheer intellect I'd say
they're pretty close Kevan Lannister
almost as smart as Tywin not quite as
shrewd KY burn very learned
smart little more sinister some of the
other characters like Prince Durant are
very learned but we haven't seen a lot
from them yet like until they reveal
some of their grand plans in much bigger
ways we won't know exactly how smart
they are usually characters demonstrate
intelligence on the show in the way that
they outwit other characters
Littlefinger is a big schemer and a
plotter I don't know how smart he's
going to be on the show compared to the
books the books make it seem like he has
a better handle on his grand plan but
that's just because his book characters
a little more opaque so really like all
those characters i just mentioned are
all really close no one of them is is
dramatically smarter than the other it's
really more about the choices that they
make Tyrion is a really good example of
a character who's really smart but
sometimes makes really bad choices
probably a bad idea to keep Shay around
you although he might have gone a little
bit insane a little bit more drunk if he
hadn't had Shay around but look how that
ended next question buren asks which
families are the wealthiest and how the
Crown's finances evolved over time which
industries are dominant in each area
City well that's a really big question
so I'll just say the show's explained it
pretty well the Lannisters are the
wealthiest in terms of like sheer
monetary value in the Tyrells are the
wealthiest in terms of assets like they
own the most land just in terms of the
Crown's finances what happens is is like
you know the long history of Targaryen
kings some of them a little bit better
with money than others and so there's
always going to be times of prosperity
when the kingdom's economy is a lot
healthier then he'll be periodic
droughts that will just put a strain on
the economy most things like that or are
mirrored on real world history China for
instances like the world's fastest
growing economy China is actually a good
way to think about et we haven't really
gone there in the show yet it's like the
Far Far East its wealth in the history
of a song of ice and fire is supposed to
have dwarfed that of ancient Valyria so
as much as people talk about the
Valerians being really powerful really
wealthy yeati at its height which you
know predated the Valyrian Empire by
quite a bit supposedly make them look
like peasants next question joaquim asks
do you think that Melisandre tried to
seduce Jon Snow because she knew he had
Kings blood like with Gendry and Stannis
R + L equal J kind of confirmed no I
don't think that she sensed anything
about his parentage I think that she
just got like a really
powerful vibe off of him so she thought
he might have Kings blood they haven't
fully explained the mechanics of it but
she does kind of have like a divining
rod in her head for Kings blood almost
like she's sensing auras from people so
she probably didn't know exactly what
was going on with Jon Snow she just knew
something was going on next question
handsomest jackass well the events in
the telltale games ever be mentioned on
the show because they are in the same
universe no it really just flows one way
like the people on the show do voices
for people in the game but I don't
expect the writers on the show to ever
acknowledge what's going on in the game
the show itself is meant to be very
self-contained to George our Martin's
books the spin-off material is really
intended to stand on its own so
technically it's not canon but because
george RR martin approves of it you
could consider it canon the way I look
at it though is that if there's any kind
of crossover like if any people from the
game are mentioned on the show any
families for instance it'll just be a
coincidence it's the same thing with the
walking dead game like I'm never
expecting to see Clementine on the
walking dead TV show next question
Joseph asks based on the events that
happened recently do you think that the
nearest whatever succumb to the madness
shown in her family so yeah that would
she turn into the next mad king no I
think the show wanted you to think that
briefly like she's like I'm not like my
father I'm not gonna roast all these
people alive when she actually ended up
kind of roasting a lot of people alive
that's mostly the writers winking at you
like hey look at history kind of
repeating itself a little bit but in the
most literal of terms no I don't think
the dinner is ever gonna go crazy mad
right now she's a couple years younger
than the Mad King was when he ascended
the throne and even though the Mad King
hadn't gone full-blown mad yet at that
time when he was her age he was still
way way nuttier but the fun part is is
that even though Daenerys probably isn't
going to go mad mad she'll still be very
vicious like you'll still see shades of
the Mad King inside of her like father
like daughter next question Andrew
Worthington asks do you think they do a
spin-off show on old Valyria or show of
the Targaryen family so using you know
just just focusing more on dragons and
people related to dragons that'd be
amazing but no I'm not expecting that
just because it will require copious
amounts of CG and that gets real
really expensive the best shot we have
at a spin-off show right now would be
Duncan egg just because a lot of the
costumes would look the same they could
get away with relatively the same amount
of CG that they do on the show right now
so from a production standpoint it costs
about the same to produce although other
they'd have new actors so it probably a
little bit cheaper don't get super
bummed out though george RR martin is
planning a book called blood and fire
which is going to be a complete history
of the Targaryen family going all the
way back to ancient Valyria but the way
he talked about it made it sound like it
wasn't going to be like a full-blown
seven book series it was gonna be like
one really really big book and he did
say that he's not going to start writing
it till he's done writing a song of ice
and fire novels which is you know
probably like four or five years away
still though that's pretty cool next
question Kade's gap asks they just
released what Ned Stark's 13 year old
self will look like he's too young for
the tower joy flashback what do you
think he'll flashback to due to the age
gap so yeah a lot of people are
speculating that a young actor on the
show is going to be playing a young Ned
Stark there is a moment in the books it
looks like they're doing this this
flashback everyone's talking about it's
literally right out of book five so I'm
not going to say what it is because
that'd be super spoilery because they're
probably going to do it think about it
in the vein of the Circe flashback at
the beginning of season five it's a very
different kind of flashback but it's
right out of the books so if you want to
know about it just read book five and if
you have read the books please use
spoiler tags who you're going to talk
about it next question Princeton asks do
you think the Tywin Lannister hated Ned
Stark because he gave the name
Kingslayer to a son Jamie well I mean he
definitely didn't like it but I don't
think anything was done out of spite Ned
Stark saw Jamie and he's like you're an
Oathbreaker you swore an oath to protect
your king Jamie said that he didn't try
to explain himself to Ned Stark so
things might have been a little bit
better if he'd had done that but who
knows what Ned would have done a lot of
the characters actually threw that in
Ned's face after he died like look at
what his honor got him Ned was a
character who was just like deeply
programmed with the ideas of honor
loyalty duty so if he had been in the
same position he probably would have
died defending the Mad King even though
it would have been the wrong thing to do
in the grand scheme of things but as for
Tywin's feelings I mean he probably saw
it more as like a minor inconvenience
just just something that made him
bristle a little bit not something that
gave him great rage next question
anna-lena asks have you seen the scripts
for the first two season episodes
circulating in the horns so you're
asking about episode scripts leaking in
what's going on with the horns from the
books and the show like the Horn of
winter that Sam supposedly found well I
think Sam is probably going to learn
more about the horns and the White
Walkers and all the lore behind that
when he's at the Citadel as for the
episode scripts no I tend to not look
for stuff like that even if it falls on
my lap I try not to pay too much mind
there was an example last year we're
part of a script between tying sand and
brawn leaked and it turned out to be
dialogue that ended up in the episode
like it was a legitimate leak but people
got so upset at the thought of spoilers
that I kind of tried to ignore like I
didn't reference it any of the videos I
done so I'm just kind of maintaining
that same stance next question furious
asks Charlie do you think we'll see
Denise go to Westeros next season or
maybe after season six well I mean she
has so much that she has left to do in
the East right now she's got a deal with
the Dothraki she's got a fixed slavers
Bay so she's not gonna be taking off
anytime soon i would say she's still
going to be in the east for all of
season six maybe towards the end of
season seven we'll see her move to
Westeros I don't think that she's going
to make landfall in Westeros before the
White Walkers come south of the wall I
would be super disappointed if the
entire war for the dawn took place north
of the wall it just seems like the wall
has to come down and that's something
that it feels like they still have to
build up to for quite a while like I
would probably poop my pants a little
bit if Melisandre were to resurrect Jon
Snow and that like the the cross effect
of the magics with the magic that's
holding the wall up brought the wall
down like that would be crazy thank you
everyone for so many questions these are
always a ton of fun to do but probably
happened like the next several weeks is
we will learn some more stuff from the
set so try to gear some of my bonus
videos around that without doing
spoilers if there's anything specific
you guys want to see just let me know
congratulations to this week's winner
zum-zum Zen you win a twenty-dollar
amazon gift card just be sure to message
me on the back of my channel so i can
get your contact info and what's
probably gonna happen is is actually i
like the idea of doing a horn of winter
videos so maybe my next bonus video on
sunday will be about the horn of winter
and don't forget in a couple we
on Sunday fear The Walking Dead is
starting so it's going to be like a big
build-up towards Walking Dead Season 6
so it'll be game of thrones and walking
dead on Sundays again pretty soon in a
couple weeks tonight there's a big press
conference for flash arrow legends of
tomorrow so I'll be doing a video for
like whatever craziest stuff they
announced for that it'll be a lot of fun
it's actually a pretty cool day for news
just in case you guys haven't seen it
you can click here to learn all about
the life history of the Mad King and how
he wasn't always mad and you can click
here for all my other Game of Thrones
bonus videos if you haven't scanned the
playlist yet I have like all the bonus
videos that I did during the season
going all the way back last year thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight so
get ready to blow out your collective
sphincters cuz my trailer is coming